anwar al boonie was jailed simply for
doing his job he served five years in a
syrian prison for his work as a human
rights lawyer trying to bring torture
charges against officials in Assad's
regime now he's in Berlin collecting
testimony from people who say they've
been tortured and building a case
against the Syrian government he's
handed at all to the public prosecutor
this is his target Jamil Hassan leader
of the Syrian Air Force Secret Service
Germany is now trying to arrest him
bounnam says it's a victory for victims
seven years now they waiting for some
hope of somebody care about their
suffering nobody care now they find this
hope and you cannot imagine how the
reaction of this victims or the Syrians
at all how it was created
yes an hour used to be an engineer now
his witness number 24 back in Syria he
protested against Assad he was
imprisoned and tortured in a Syrian Air
Force jail the same jail the Jamil
Hassan was in charge of you can't know
if it's now day or night you can't know
if you will eat after two or four hours
or you are allowed to sleep definitely
are not allowed to speak side nya is
serious most notorious prison what
happens behind closed doors here is not
seen but we know what the results look
like a military photographer smuggled
out pictures of the dead when he
defected each of his photos suggests
systematic torture
geopolitics have prevented the
International Criminal Court from taking
action bashar al-assad is protected by
his alliance with Russian President
Vladimir Putin but Alba me and his team
have found a willing partner in Berlin
Germany is the only country to consider
pressing charges under the principle of
universal jurisdiction enabling any
country to prosecute war crimes no
matter where they've been perpetrated
Hamid had with this Germany's chief
prosecutors have made a huge step ahead
of other nations other countries should
see this as an example of what action
they could take because this task cannot
rest solely on the shoulders of the
German judiciary it's really will be to
prove to European and to them self
justice as principal it's not under
control of politic that is very
important to us and to the world the
case represents a strong signal from
Germany's judiciary to President Assad
suspected war criminals and torturers
will be prosecuted